- Is it weird when you go--
because we go to Disneyland
with some of our kids, right?
- Yeah.
- Your kids want to see the princesses--
- Obviously, so, you know,
what's it like, you running into you?
- Well, let me start by saying,
I'm a firm believer that
there is no ownership, right?
- But there is the OG, but okay, cool.
- Right, I'm OG Anna, for sure.
But the one thing that's weird is that
when you talk to them, you've
probably experienced this,
they can't break.
- (Kelly) No.
- (Kristin) So, I go up,
and we're taking a picture,
and I'm like, "Hi, how are you?"
And she's like, "Arendelle
is beautiful today!"
(audience laughs) (Kelly laughs and claps)
- And I'm like, "Okay, she's...
alright, I'll ask Elsa."
And I'm like, "How are you doing?"
And she's like, "The ice has just melted,
and Olaf is thrilled
with the summer weather."
And I'm like, all I want to do is go,
blink twice if you need to be rescued,
because this is crazy. (audience laughs)
- It's crazy to adults,
but the kids love it.
- (Kristen) The kids
love it, but it is weird
to the adults--
- (Kelly) Yeah, yeah.
- And they're doing this and stuff--
- Yeah, and they laugh,
like Snow White's my favorite, it's like
(laughs cartoonishly)
And I'm like, I'm just creeped out.
- It's really, it's funny.
- (Kelly) But my kids love it.
- Oh the kids don't,
they don't see anything
wrong with it.
- (Kelly) Yeah, if they broke character,
my kids would cry.